where would you drive on this off ramp  let's take a look at many examples of  humans driving their cars here  notice anything  they all cut the corner going over the  right lane line to drive to the middle  [Music]  what would every stock lane keep assist  system do  he'd probably hug left since it's  hard-coded to never cross a lane line  but if the goal is to drive like a human  this is wrong  let's see what open pilot with blameless  does  [Music]  since we have an end-to-end driving  model that learns where to drive based  on humans it drives the correct path  [Music]  watch our cto talk about laneless and  his comic-con talk and get openpilot to  try laneless for yourself  [Music]